this week the Home Secretary Sajid Javid
announced a new approach to tackling the
scourge of violent crime he's pledged
200 million pounds to create a joint of
approach and a legal duty between
different agencies including health
services schools and local councils to
work together to tackle the problem
whilst I think this approach is a great
step in the right direction we must also
be realistic reports say that this new
setup will be a public health approach
to violent crime but joining a gang
heading out stabbing killing maiming and
terrorizing others often over something
as basic as the purse code that you
somehow seem to think that you own is
ultimately a choice and while it's all
well and good trying to help these
people we must also make sure that they
understand that ultimately it is them
and them alone who are responsible for
their choices and when the wrong choices
are made lauren order must kick in
[Music]
Michelle we thought you we seem to have
had this same debate a million times
already
killing each other well the thing is I
don't understand your point because of
course Lord Lord is gonna kick in and
it's about looking at patterns clearly
there's a disproportionate amount of
people in prison with learning
difficulties with mental illness kids
who've been a product of our care system
and so on and so on so surely there's a
link all of the data suggests there is
so taking this 360 approach makes sense
he's not saying that law and order won't
kick him he's saying that there is a
problem with seeing patterns we're
seeing who is most likely to end up in
prison it's people who have experience
of things that I've just mentioned so
therefore we need a 360 approach to deal
with it we do need a 360 approach to
deal with there and I said in my intro
that's a great thing but I can't help
but feel that where we seem to be
glossing over the fact that these kids
I'm making a choice so don't take my
word for it just listen to this guy I've
sorted Mercer all the money I've told it
dude as it was hard for us to get a good
opportunity
to be someone good to be somewhat
successful she came to us easy we
started this game and it was like a game
to us do you think that the me reason as
to why they're getting into this road
life and they're getting involved at
Lourdes crime is because their
background isn't the best some people
come from a good background some people
choose it the unknown unknown copy use
they come from very comfortable good
background enough
and obviously they said yeah are they
like the lifestyle because they're no
couple meets you've done it there's a
deer let me join them they want to do
after the old kids who's come from
Chelsea everywhere
good night smart good master but they've
chose to use so my point is as you had
that I've chosen to do it it's a game
and I do this for the money why are you
rolling your eyes if you showed this
clip last time and I'm bored now I'm so
I wish they'd stop doing it so back to
what you just said there I remember a
few weeks ago you sat in the same space
it's been advocating for early
intervention for child molesters so how
is this any different how is this any
different in terms of us having some
early intervention because at the end of
the day and what I spoke about was when
someone identifies that they are a
pedophile right help and support should
be available to them that's a sick child
into this well I'll explain that's a
situation where once identified that
there is a young boy where somebody has
identified you know I am a problem they
should be supported my point in all of
this is there seems to be a complete
it's not even there that there's a lack
of responsibility that we're saying to
these children this is a choice you are
choosing to you're choosing to do it
sorry going on I just um because I don't
think there's necessarily a
contradiction between it being a choice
in the sense that the law will always
apply and I once had a former gang
member on my show on my radio show and I
asked him how he counseling I did as
well and I asked him how he counsels in
his interventions and the strongest
lines he led with was this he would tell
people to take responsibility but I
don't see that as contradicting the
other point which is the evidence shows
and research consistently shows that
kids expelled from school
are vulnerable to being targeted by a
gang so I had a debate show where so
I'll tell you why
so I'll tell you why sir ADHD so they
have a lot of these kids have had ADHD
they get expelled for their what are
their being told and minor disruptions
but they're repetitive they're going to
special schools PR use yeah
and those PR use the gangs like grooming
gangs in Rochdale with sex crimes there
are criminal gangs that in exactly the
same way bribe these kids as young as 12
years old with gifts of Nikes and Adidas
trainers then they tell them you know
now you owe us money you're in debt just
make this delivery fully off and the
reason they're targeting 12 year olds
and 13 year olds is because they're too
young to be stopped by police and
searched so we've got children being
exploited in this way as well so it's
it's broader than just 18 year olds
taking responsibility for stabbing each
it's 12 year olds or 13 year olds right
my perception on this whole thing is and
I have been that kid once right so I was
I was in the children zone I had
numerous offenses Bloods against me and
went to court two or three times okay so
I was going down that road where I was
going to land myself in serious trouble
now it wasn't there were two or three
things toward me out one was myself yeah
okay because you have to take ownership
of what you're doing and if you can't
take ownership of what you're doing then
you're going to be led by other people
in whatever direction it is they decide
to take you
the other one was breaking that chain of
going with the wrong people so I've got
involved to an activity center and I did
a lot of instructional work there I
looked after me and I mentored me okay
this is one game but it's the mentoring
thing he's keen okay
all right the third thing that happened
was there was a deterrent I don't wanna
go to prison and I don't want to go to
prison for a long time okay and I was
told all about it and I met various
people who'd been to prison and all that
sort of stuff so I do believe in this
the prevention is better than cure that
has to make your and it has to be a
problems with the law I was about 13
years old when you turn yourself around
when I turn myself around I was about 15
to 16 because I saw I thought I had a
come-to-jesus moment in me I know but I
on a minute feel you go in the wrong way
and you getting that moment come to
jesus to these kids have gone right boom
yeah because of the army saved you as
well I'd say Adamic the Arvin is a big
factor on my progression and out of it
at that actual moment when I turned
myself over flip myself on my head and
went yeah I feel you've got to sort this
out seriously that was my call come to
Jesus moment and I wouldn't have had
that if I'd have kept knocking around in
the same circles we just see before we
go telling you trying to get off for him
but there's a because on
prevention is a police officer in
Glasgow because this the whole thing
about addressing it from a health
perspective came from the Glasgow
experiment which itself was borrowed
from Chicago but there's a policeman in
Glasgow and he says it reflecting on
this we've got to understand what the
problems are the police for years have
been experts at detection and
enforcement I'd much rather be top of
the cliff putting a fence up stopping
somebody jumping over as at the bottom
of the cliff waiting until they've
jumped that's the public health approach
as far as I'm concerned you're
engineering out issues rather than
waiting for them to happen which I think
resonates well with some of what you
said I've been listening to because I
think this is really a complex area and
I think there's something in all
everything what would you say that I
agree well there I've got some sympathy
for you're saying Michelle and I think
but I would put it in it I would put it
in a context where actually if you look
at Britain and coal I think cultural
attitudes are really important here we
have a particular attachment to the
concept of punishment in Britain and we
have done going back centuries and even
when it's be shown over and over again
that our prisons don't make people
better they actually make them worse
they're more likely to Rhea fend you
still sentence people to go there
because we believe that we should be
punished even when it's causing more
suffering for all of us because it
produces more criminality if you and and
the sympathy I have with what gene said
there are a range of factors that make
children really vulnerable to crime
fifty percent of young offenders in
prison have been in care I find that
scandalous because these are young
people who the state has as a captive
audience to do to no difficulties in
mental ill and I would say you know look
at what rich people do for their
children
rich people put their children in
beautiful schools with lots of outdoor
space good food stimulating activities
small class sizes help nurture their
passions and their talents teach them
languages and crafts and are and take
them on outings and they produce people
who are interested ambitious we look at
look at what we do with poor kids we put
them in large class sizes in
understaffed under-resourced schools
Prue's are a scandal I've done some
investigations on them and they're a
scandal we put the most trouble kids
together in an environment where they're
not being given any aspiration and then
we're surprised that they end up in jail
to say that um it isn't about
necessarily helping them once they've
committed a crime it's actually about
when you look at the preventative side
it's helping all of us because the
consequences of crime don't just impact
the victim and the perpetrator they
impact the entire neighborhood just to
be
I'm not saying don't help and support
these kids so I'm not saying Chuck all
these kids away and forget about them
what I'm saying is whilst I think this
approach is very good it seems to be
also completely forgetting about a very
important aspect of this which is
personal choice that is my problem I
know we shouldn't patronize these
children they do have choices I just
want to show you a statistic about
because there it there is an increase in
particular kinds of violent crimes so
last year there were forty thousand
offenses involving knives or sharp
instruments and that was a 16 percent
increase on the year before and the
crime survey for England Wales said that
there was no change in overall violent
offences so what that means is that
within violent offences offenses
involving knives and other sharp
instruments had gone up but that to me
is more evidence that we should take a
public health approach because this is
something that is like it is like an
epidemic it's increasing and I think we
need to look at the causes but I like
where I agree with you as well as I'm a
bit skeptical about some of these
political announcements so for example
the idea of creating a unit that is kind
of dedicated to this
I think distracts the tension from the
fact this is public service it worked in
Glasgow at one time Glasgow was deemed
the most dangerous in the developed
world and they did set up a specialized
crime unit and they've dropped the
murder rate right down but I'm being
slightly using my advantage in taking
control of this debate because I'm gonna
get the last word we have to move on
sorry sorry it was a very cheap shot I
apologize but we do have to move on